all right it's movie retrospective time
going back to 1986 to my teenage years
yeah I was in high school at this time
yeah I saw this movie that the labyrinth
yeah or just labyrinth yeah yeah now
this just labyrinth yeah I'm pretty sure
it's yeah we're gonna be Jim Henson's
doing Ruby we got it the other day on
blu-ray steelbook yeah check that [ __ ]
and this thing is huge it's beautiful
it's kind of a metallic blue there's
nothing inside there is some bonus
features but we're gonna do a review of
the blu-ray and the story of course we
didn't talk about the story yeah this
was one of my favorite movies growing up
like I think I was 14 years old when it
came out which that's about the same age
as Jennifer Connelly was when choosing
this I think she was 14 or 15 yeah I was
a couple years older when I first saw
this I actually saw it to see David
Bowie because I was I actually had all
this album yeah the tape of the music
off of this but I hadn't seen the movie
it was like man a music pretty good yeah
I mean it's kind of kid like but it's
still boat doing what but we does you
know and then I watch the movie we saw
it on VHS I didn't see it in the theater
I don't think I saw this in the theater
either I might have seen it like a year
or two after kid when I came out of like
HBO seeing it on blu-ray man it looks
great it's a it looks very expensive
the puppetry all it was done by Jim
Henson and just the way that it's shot
and the way everything looks it looks
fantastic now you can tell as some of
the backdrops and the very backs are
paintings and matte paintings but yeah
doesn't matter because the world is not
supposed to look realistic in this movie
yeah it's a fantasy it's a fantasy yeah
it looks really good and I have to say I
mean really as far as I'm concerned like
Jim Henson can pretty much do no wrong I
mean I love the Muppets
I love Fraggle Rock I still do you know
what I mean so yeah I feel like this
movie and this is another one this just
like blows my mind I didn't realize this
at the time I guess because like I said
I don't think I saw this in the theater
I think I saw it like a year later when
it came out on cable and I just loved
the movie like immediately but I didn't
really realize that when it
you know when it came to theaters it was
kind of a box-office failure like it
cost 25 million to make and it only made
about half of its money back
during its us theatrical run and it got
like kind of not that great reviews
either which that's just like on this
board by the standards were different
then I guess they had actually had high
standards thicken they took fantastic
special effects and production values
just kind of for granted back then he
was everything that's supposed to be
very handcrafted and so they just they
were kind of used to it and they were
kind of used to good stories so the
competition was great
stiff back then when you put this up
with something today like maybe a Pixar
film I mean this would win hands down if
you ask me because everything you're
seeing is is really there yeah I mean
the only things that they did CGI we're
like the owl the barn owl at the
beginning that mean doesn't look that
good really well and that do you know
that that is actually the first ever as
far as I'm aware the first instance of a
realistic CGI animal in a movie yeah I
think it was supposed to be slightly
mechanical wooden or made out of crystal
or something it was supposed to look
real but then again I might be getting
it confused with Bubo from Jennifer was
cute as hell I mean you know when I
first saw it I was like man that girl's
damn cute she's adorable
yeah she's in a later battle angel she's
like I said a few years younger than me
says she's your age yeah she said hasn't
changed much she's Duke not really I
mean she's aged very very well yeah yeah
cuz we were just watching a lead of
battle angel again it was like man she
still looks good and she has that same
jawline and I'll tell you what the
jawline is what gives your age away yeah
that's and you know they're spending
money well there's been and money that's
their lively they have money you're
gonna spend money you might as well get
some nips and toxins yeah I would if I
had the money
she looks great though she really does
yeah and she's been in like such
fantastic movies yeah I think I'm as far
as I know this is her first one you know
what's weird it was like I'm reading the
Wikipedia page about this movie
and it's like apparently we'll see okay
now the you know the the path this took
like to get to the actual theater it was
like a two or three year process I mean
like the the script went through like 25
different versions it's like they were
originally gonna set it in like
Victorian England like it was gonna be a
Victorian England girl you know there
were some iterations where the Goblin
King was like much more of a villain or
where he appeared to her like in a
different guise of like someone that she
knew [ __ ] like that they decided that in
the end that they were gonna make it
like more they thought it would make him
more commercial and more relatable if it
was like a modern American girl like
going back into this fantasy world but I
thought it was interesting because like
some of the actresses that tried out for
this and I'm like wow this really would
have been different Helena Bonham Carter
Sarah Jessica Parker you'd have been
weird um who else
it was Ally Sheedy she that might have
wanted that'll work that might have
worked um there was a couple other ones
that I thought were very strange that
probably wouldn't work now for David
Bowie like I said it's kind of hard to
although Ally was a little old that's I
thought she was up because she was in
she would have been a little old yeah
because she was in almost John Hughes
movies right and I think she was a
couple years older than Jennifer
Connelly now Jennifer Connelly I think
like I said she's the same age as me so
she was 14 when those 40 was made
although she looks slightly older in the
Saline especially I think in the
ballroom scene which she has all the me
a dress on I was saying at the time and
said boy she looks a lot older right
there it says if you were to tell me
that that girl was 20 I believe you yeah
and she was made up but then you know
when she that's what gets dudes in
trouble sometimes when this when this
movie came out I really I really didn't
understand it you know as a 16 17 year
old guy a lot of this was kind of over
my head these little drizzle riddles and
puzzles yes but now that I'm older you
know as I got old right it was clearly a
tale about it it's it's a coming-of-age
tale it's a it's a warning
to young girls about how to deal with
these men yeah and
her and a bunch of different her being
surrounded by a bunch of unsuitable men
they're all unsuitable for and she's
going through this story some of her to
old once little little advice T but no
strength the other ones all strength but
he's but it's Bradley and he's dumb you
know that's all that ever kind of money
you got you got Bowie who's this
supposedly kind of abusive all-powerful
Rockstar super sexy [ __ ] he's
like a king but he's way too old for you
yeah you know the super control any
super control and he's a bunch got a
bunch of women that you know that are
waiting on him so you don't know you you
know young girl would have no power over
would have no power over me that's what
this that's what this story's about I
would actually recommend this movie to
any woman who wanted to give this to her
young daughter yeah this is really one
of the best coming-of-age type stories
how to deal with these dudes it's got
yeah and it's got kind of like I
realized it at the time cuz you know I
was 14 euros realized [ __ ] got it and
it's like if you if you read like people
that are the same age as me that saw
this when it first came out
these girls immediately got it they did
exactly what they were talking about
because there's like a not unsubtle
undercurrent of sex in this yeah and I
think we're contractually obligated to
mention David Bowie's jacket fantasy
about David Bowie and me David Bowie's
pants yeah it's not gonna cash no God
rest his soul I know right and he was in
his forties when this movie came out and
he looking good man looking like a you
know looking like a rock star and now
maybe metal hair yeah Gareth outfit is
famous Gareth outfit right yeah it's
like and it's funny because when I was
talking about all the different
actresses that tried out for the role of
Sarah in this movie like I think Jim
Henson from the beginning for the Goblin
King role he wanted a rockstar um I
don't know if David Bowie was his first
choice but one
like he had kind of a pool of
possibilities which also included Mick
Jagger sting he might have been alright
yeah sting would have done great yeah he
would've cuz he was in the bride and he
was awesome brimstone truth that's right
he was in that - oh we got to do that he
couldn't do it and he could sing and
dance yeah greatness although I'm glad
that Bowie got this I did because he has
like sting is awesome but I've always
got that something some Bowie's more
sluggish and more in drugs and more yeah
which any [ __ ] a yeah which I think
worked a lot better love it because like
I said it's not unsubtle there is a very
like there's a very strong sexual
undercurrent to this he is a closeted
heterosexual his last video before he
died he goes backwards into the closet
he tells them tell them I was always a
closeted heterosexual it's like funny
till the end
he's [ __ ] funny yeah you don't have
like a rock star it really did he lives
the life of a [ __ ] rock so even
though he really didn't make his money
in rock he made his money in real estate
I mean if you Paul McCartney yeah I
think collecting yeah you're smart you
get into like he's an earth defy yeah
David Bowie did not have the ability to
lose money he knew how to make money and
he didn't make it with those records
really yeah once once he once he did
that let's dance album he had enough -
pocket to becoming a multi
multi-millionaire I think they said that
he was the richest entertainer the
richest man in music but he made almost
none of that in music yeah you know I
think that makes sense I think the guy
who made the most in music prior to
Michael Jackson yeah he was another one
that was considered for this role which
yeah that would be that would gone over
like a fart in a spacesuit yeah I don't
know what the Prince was another one
that was the rest what a downer well it
might have worked that would have worked
that might have worked probably worked
sting would have worked yeah Mick Jagger
might have worked he was old at this
time but he was even pretty old in 1986
earlier he looked old I don't know if
you
could have only been Bowie or sting yeah
oh I was gonna say maybe had a man but I
don't think any man was really doing too
well at that time when he had a star
power but yeah interesting he could act
though oh yeah he was in a lot of movies
actually I saw a lot of movies but yeah
so I was just like trying to look like I
said I wouldn't change anything about
this movie because I think it's like
assertive but I was just like you know
when I was trading with all the other
actors I was like thinking it's like huh
what would that I think the reason why
this you know this really didn't make a
bunch of money at the time it was kind
of quickly forgotten was because I think
they were comparing it to legend and
visually legend kind of blows this away
although legend I don't think did very
well either no no that had only come out
the year before yeah there was a lot of
movies like this coming out yeah the 80s
were kind of like fantasies though over
they were all stepping on each other's
dicks and I think timing was wrong for
labyrinth maybe had it come out a little
early
or maybe much later but Bowie's still
that same age if maybe would have done a
little bit better
nothing is it's also very hard to market
a movie like this this is a movie
actually targeted at moms and teenage
girls yeah it's like it's kind of like a
kids movie but not not really it's kind
of like okay it's a fake kids movie yeah
it's like a kid's movie but it's not
really I mean what they wanted to do I
mean when they started working on this
and like I said Jim Hansen directed it
George Lucas also executive produced and
he worked on some of the script rewrites
and stuff as well and it was actually
based on like creatures and drawings and
stuff by Brian Froud and I think that
the screenplay a lot of the screenplays
written by Terry Jones of Monty Python
Fame so although a lot of other people
had their fingers in the pie as well but
it's kind of like they had you know they
had all done the Dark Crystal like a
year or two before which did pretty well
but they said well no logical to me now
it turned out much darker than they had
intended and it's weird because I liked
labyrinth in the Dark Crystal about the
same back in the 80s but watching them
now I think lip labyrinth is aged a lot
better yeah I learned the first love
this pace of that stories really [ __ ]
up
well yeah it's kind of it drags a bit
and also there's a little bit of tonal
whiplash because it's like it's very
very dark like all this gets this and
stuff and they're all scary and then
they have like fee and then they have
like that little goofy like fizzgig that
little dong the voice all the time the
voice has become too much after about 15
minutes you get sick of those damn
Skeksis voices it just gets me this
movie I could watch this movie you know
once a week yeah I could watch this all
day especially on poor fun this blu-ray
you can see how good those costumes and
those puppets and the in the sense look
I mean they look they were really well
made yeah
they worked on this for like almost two
years like building puppets and painting
the sets and all those other kind of
stuff and it's like and another thing
too and I guess I mean I realized this
but it didn't really hit home for me
until I was watching some of the
documentaries about it they're like you
look at a character you know the
character of hoggle you know the little
the little dwarf guy and they're like
okay well there's um you know there's a
little person inside of that a woman my
name is sherry Weiser I think was her
name and she's inside the suit like
walking around and [ __ ] but the face and
the voice and everything like that
that's for other dudes yeah like out
like over there you know in the camera
looks and they all have to work like in
synchrony yeah and it looks more
realistic to me than that original Yoda
puppet from the oh yeah it did these
things look pretty real they do and the
things that don't look real is supposed
to not look real it's yeah like you're
in an amusement park like everything's
that you've got an amusement park tone
to it yeah it's a trip and then another
thing is is that every part of this
story has like a an alternate message
and a bunch of subliminal messaging yeah
it has like a lot of symbolic yeah so
the story is very well crafted
especially from a mythological point of
view yeah it has a lot of elements of
seeing like religious tales yeah like
gold Greek epic he's actually Greek
yeah I mean you know the first thing she
does when she arrives in the labyrinth
and she's in a labyrinth well kind of
labyrinth business it's the world of
adulthood that's what they're talking
about that's what the labyrinth is and
and what's she trying to find she's
trying to get this baby yeah there's all
these guys involved so it's all over and
as soon as she shows up she can't tell
in the maze she didn't she goes I don't
know if I should go less left or right I
guess it doesn't matter and Huggle says
all you got a lot to learn so the first
thing to tell you in the story is as a
kid you should know that your decisions
matter yeah that's that's what life is
about and then the first thing she meets
is a worm who's a nice to know missus
and he's got the kids symbolic of a
married man who's he satisfied he's got
nothing to offer she wants nothing from
him he's just kind of insignificant and
he can't help her so then she keeps on
going deeper into the Lord he does help
her because she says there's no way into
the labyrinth and he said you're not
looking right that's right he sent her
the wrong way though yeah remember that
well yeah but he's gone that way she
would've gone right to the edge of a
castle right to the castle so he did
tell her to like look at things because
she was just seeing it as a flat wall
some advice to live by but then all of a
sudden there's all this weird [ __ ] like
Oh a wise man shows up a as Kim
something he doesn't know [ __ ] so the
more all the stories don't listen to
these old [ __ ] some people get so low
they can't help you the bird on his
hairline is smarter than ya stimulating
being your Hey yeah everything
everything has a lesson to teach a
person even an adult really well it
reminds an adult of the lesson and even
gets there's even warnings involved in
the very end she gets a warning of don't
become a hoarder a bag lady bag lady
hoarder well don't hang on to the past
yeah cuz that's what happens to people
do women that hang on to the past too
long and live in the past and they're
not living in the present they only care
about the things in the past all sudden
they're living in a damn hoard yeah you
become like a cat yeah they try to make
her a hoarder
yes pile on all the stuff on her is good
she failed she failed
she failed with this goblin king there's
one but you have to see the movie
everybody sees this yeah she goes to the
club the Goblin King's there and she's
looking like a princess but then there's
all these other bad women who are lining
up behind everybody's wearing masks and
the noses look like big dicks yeah they
look like [ __ ] like look at the [ __ ] in
the background there's there's some it's
a lesson to her that don't think you're
gonna show up in a grown man's life like
you're some kind of magical princess
this dude's got all kinds of other women
and all kinds of other stuff that's been
going on in his past you know what I
mean so she was raped and then it
shatters like it yeah she shatters like
so the illusion is shattered to this guy
yeah something that like I said I was
exactly the same age as her as she was
when this movie came out and it's
something that a lot of teenage girls
because teenage girls not all of them
obviously but a lot of them are kind of
prone to like Romanticism and you know
they they get some like sweet sounding
line from a guy and they like just go
off and just ruin your whole [ __ ]
life yeah so I think that that's good
this is good because it's a cautionary
tale because it's like yes David Bowie
shows up in your house yes I can pack
witless waah and his magical balls in
his hair he's got balls in his pants and
do all this [ __ ] playing with his balls
and he's and he's like saying he's doing
all this stuff for you and it's like a
dog defining damn you yeah and it's just
like so I think that's why like it's
significant at the end when she finally
remembers the line for the flavors that
you have no power
yes she does oh you know what you ain't
[ __ ] you got a power yeah yeah I can
just leave well because here's the thing
I she gets the baby yeah does get the
baby noises yeah fertility it's also
responsibility yeah respond his buddy
yeah um you know because that's
something that she didn't want you know
she's got all these toys she doesn't
want to grow up she's bratty you know at
the beginning she's like nothing's fair
never bad
yes she finds that real quick that
nothing is fair yes and then she that's
one thing that she learns in the
labyrinth - she's like cuz yeah results
need to start learning she's fighting
with hoggle and like she takes his [ __ ]
which takes his family jewels away takes
his fanny yeah yes like I said
everything is a sexual innuendoes yeah
here's and then he says it's not fair
and she's like that's right but that's
just the way it isn't she's like oh I
just figured that out yeah and the funny
thing is is that you know if you've
never seen this movie it is suitable for
young girls it is it's not it's not it's
classy it's not yeah yeah at all I mean
if you're not like what you have to read
into it from not not that hard but you
do have an adult knows what's going on
and I think a teenager would they're
like you know they like okay yeah I
think I know what they're saying there
that's yeah yeah yeah now I'm gonna kid
a ten-year-old girl wouldn't get any of
this I don't think maybe now maybe now
that we have the yeah yeah that's true
they're they're growing up a little bit
different and I have to tell you that
there's like 40 million jillion
different like theories about this movie
and like some stuff that I didn't even
realize I didn't even realize this [ __ ]
but check it out so they're talking
about the first time that Sarah meets
hoggle they're like now the first time
she meets him what's he doing he's
peeing in a pond like you standing there
was dick in his hands yeah she's like so
and also they said that if you notice
they're like it's really obvious when
you know about it but it's what just
kind of passed by if you weren't but if
you notice like the back of his jacket
it's got two faces on it because he's
too based okay like janus like you know
what I mean cuz he's kind of playing
both sides against a kid because he's a
coward
he's a cowardly old man that you as a
young girl want nothing to do with that
dude he's nice to you but he's also of
love with you and but you can't trust
him yeah and then but I mean he like
roofies her yeah but then eventually
eventually she does kind of work out a
situation with him though she
manipulates him for a while but then
they do because oh they do become
friends I guess and then jerath makes
fun of him for even thinking that she
could you know yes care about it you
know there's old man
lessons there to see everybody warrants
in here there's old man lessons there
well I feel like I mean obviously a big
big thing that this was based on was
Wizard of Oz I mean this is a kind of
story Dorothy Gale she's you know in her
house and like she's like oh my life is
so boring I live in the stupid farm in
Kansas and I don't like my family la
blah blah then she gets whisked off to
this magical land with witches and
munchkins and whatnot and the lesson
there and you know meets three dudes
just like in this movie um that are like
represent different personality traits
or things that she needs
yeah the foxy little dude that's all
bark and no bite you can talk his ass
off but just can't know the other ones a
big old Ludo Ludo a big monstrous super
strong guy who's just dumb friendly
although he can control you can control
rods that's pretty rad but she didn't
want to go out with him you need these
guys they're all supposed to be
different options I think in a woman's
life and you know that's what there's
the reference all the mr. wrong they're
all bad they're all bad yeah but good
for it good for friendship because they
have other like koalas that you love it
these aren't these don't have much to do
with directly giving you that baby she's
chasing four that's how I you don't want
the baby with that that's gonna turn ass
that's the message I what would a human
ludo baby look like it's just all the
possibilities young woman out in front
it's a minefield out there lacy it's a
whole Lab is obviously influenced a lot
by Wizard of Oz like I said that you
know the the message of Wizard of Oz it
was kind of more telling girls oh don't
go seeking happiness or fortune just
just stay home
yes which I didn't really realize at the
time but now the more I think about it
I'm like yeah they're kind of just up
just be happy where you are just shut up
know your place those were the values of
the time then yeah so that's that's why
but um this was also uh
influenced a lot so much so that there
was almost a lawsuit about it by the
book Maurice Sendak's book outside over
there which also had a girl whose baby
sister was taken by goblins and kind of
a similar thing happened and actually
his estate like kind of threatened it
was like hey can you like not start not
work on that movie because it's just
like my book but they like came to an
agreement
so yeah they paid him off and and
actually at the end of it at the end of
labyrinth like Jim Henson had a message
on there like credited crediting him
because I guess that's kind of where the
story must been similar maybe there was
some inspiration from theirs yeah I mean
the thing is I don't know like it's been
a long time since I read that book so I
don't know if it's exactly so like I
don't know if there's a labyrinth in or
anything like that I mean yeah there's
like a goblin steals baby but I mean
goblins and mythology steal baby steal
babies I mean that's what they do and
that's kind of where Brian Froud got the
idea when they were talking about
because he said the whole image that he
had in his head that was like the
inspiration for this because like I said
they'd been working on the Dark Crystal
and they said we want to do something
like a look a bit lighter more fun
something with a couple of human
characters you know with and more
interaction with the puppets and
something that's just like not so heavy
so he had the idea of a baby like a
human baby like surrounded by a bunch of
goblins and he thought that was a really
cool idea and he's like yeah goblins
they steal babies in mythology so then
he kind of like wrote a story like I
said this story went through like a
bunch of different iterations before it
got to the form that it was in um I
think actually one of the early ones
that I thought this was kind of
interesting but jerath comes to Sarah's
house like under a glamour like he's it
he's um the author of a play that she's
gonna be in because you know she's doing
the play at the beginning of the movie
yeah and he shows up at the house and
she doesn't she doesn't ask him to take
the baby he just takes it
okaywe yeah in them so he's like a bad
guy in the movie he just shows up in the
form of an owl yeah so yeah but there
doesn't take he does she asks she asks
him to take the baby he does take the
baby but I think it's just the goblins
that take the baby under his command
right she turns around baby's gone
yeah they don't show cuz yeah you can
hear yeah yeah but
I said and I think it's interesting to
like the whole thing about now see I'm
gonna say right here and I know there's
a lot of different theories about this
and everything I think that the whole
movie takes place in Sarah's imagination
well of course because all of this stuff
like all of the characters that she
meets including Jairus and including
like all of my buddies
she has like little stuffed toys are
like little momma's of them in her Ridge
she's got a little doll of jerath right
there near by her mirror and all in a
lot of little characters there and I
think there's a picture on her mirror of
David Bowie - yeah it's kind of uh I
always interpreted it as this is
something that's playing out in her
subconscious yes all of all these
iridology issues sure that she has and
you're going on this trip with her
inside her in her mind seeing these but
yeah so I don't think the baby really
got kidnapped or anything like that I
think that was like her kind of working
out for issues I'm like coming so yeah
it's like a symbolic story like a
symbolic journey it's not the movie is a
great date movie Jenny and I watched it
and in this in this format right here
okay we'd have a good sound system good
television and [ __ ] so we're singing
along though we were singing along the
songs drinkin's magic exactly actually
the the that song what was the name of
those characters a little fire the fire
ease or the fire fire ease yeah I was
that sounds called chilly down I think
chilly down I always wondered what that
was but I see it now they're fighting
over who's gonna give who's head and can
you take somebody's head from them and
you can give someone yeah head yeah
everything you handle scene was as it
was about hedonism yeah cuz remember she
didn't she was like tempted by hedonism
business oh this is just stupid yeah
because they didn't worry about anything
or anybody
they had never aim lessly everybody had
and they had Jamaican accent making
access I think they kind of out in the
woods giving each other hand around the
fire taking head of getting head from on
today's her head does it come on offer
and really you know like I say you have
some living head
yeah yeah it's not real obvious you know
kid doesn't know not to a kid I can't
believe it but even adults easy cuz yeah
it's all about although like I said I
mean watching the movie now it's very
very clear that they were trying to
focus on David Bowie's area oh yeah I
mean there are some shots in there where
there's like he's like knocking a Huggle
or something and it's just right there
it's well this is this is because of the
type of the nature of the story yeah
alright that character is a phallic
character oh yeah and they're making it
clear that this is did they're making it
clear cinema in cinematography that this
is about sex
yeah and that this dude is sexually
threatening you know yeah and like I
said they really that's why I think he
was perfect for this role because you
can see how you would be tempted by that
kind of stuff cuz he's like I said some
super foxy white star shows up in your
house yeah it's like now that was my
baby and you know when I when I was in
high school every 15 16 year old girl
saw this I think they knew it was about
em they knew it as about because we were
we were we were tapping all that back in
those days anyway well yeah old people
[ __ ] were getting down back in the
80s I call them well they're old now but
now in the eighties it was in the
eighties you know we were [ __ ]
blowing the doors off it was a very
different high school I'm reading now
these young kids now they're in high
school and even out they're not having
much sex anymore although I heard they
were even worse than the seven days no
actually they're probably worse than the
50s and the 60s we didn't talk about it
yes yes
and then Leon kind of people are not
very active today they're kind of scared
the back in the day but you weren't
scared yeah I'm scared no I know
no need well I'm like I said we didn't
even have the internet you said I like
figure [ __ ] out for yourself man
or like I tell stories I'm not gonna
tell stories but you know what we had
drive-ins and triads were like [ __ ]
motels well yeah nobody ever watched the
movie if the [ __ ] dl3 cars down your
boy and his girlfriend yeah yeah and
then like you know sometimes you know
you you and your girl be in the
your boy and his girlfriend be in the
backseat you'd be high-fiving each other
cross back machine
the girls will be talking pass the
cigarettes and [ __ ] you're mad at your
imagination right a while I don't know
you filled that in pretty funny oh yeah
like I said I think everybody and you
know probably girls that age that watch
this nowadays yeah because I have heard
you know obviously because you know I'm
of an age now where you know I wear I
know people that have daughters that are
about you know that are preteens or
whatever yeah and I knew I've known a
couple people that showed their
daughters this at that age and they got
it right away they noticed it right away
yes so like I said it's not it's polite
about it but you did yeah it's like I
said it's still a family movie it's like
you don't feel like cover anyone's eyes
or anything like that but it's for kid
kids kind of it's it's yeah but it is
subtle and it is a very very sexual yeah
story it's a sexual awakening yeah it is
yeah so talked to you in a very g-rated
way in a g-rated way yeah actually a
g-rated maybe PG because I think this
might be repeating there are some things
that Bowie says he is any no one can
blame you for walking away what he said
too much protection no love injection
that's great he does say love injection
Robbins on too much action on and not
enough loving it's a sexual or ever in
in that's right as the story's opening
yeah protecting that girl too much not
enough love injection she's not getting
well that's what she I wanna babysit
she's had enough of this [ __ ] love
injection I guess so that's what you
know you couldn't tell this story today
I don't know I don't think you could
tell the story today that's gay it's
like I don't know him it's like kind of
like in a way I kind of like I generally
was really good as new
in the underground goddesses like it's
so funny because like why I mean it now
like holy crab it's so dirty
yeah but fun dirty in a fun way it's
like Muppets but also yeah
yeah and like I had a attention ticketed
yeah and like I said we're not the first
people to say this because there's like
[ __ ] there's like that [ __ ]
fanfiction site like that big fanfiction
fanfiction.net or whatever it is it's
got like 8,000 [ __ ] stories about
labyrinth on there yeah sure almost all
of them have to do with well that's not
a big stretch that's not a big leap
though at all no that's what I mean it's
pretty much just hanging right out there
for a notch look at those pouty ass we
got his [ __ ] pouty face on another
gone pout like I said I think he was
like really the best choice for this
just because I mean David Bowie and
pretty much every other role he was in
he seemed like not from here like he
seemed like otherworldly that's why they
put him in the man who fell to earth
yeah and the husband is a vampire
specially in his time I mean you know we
go to the clubs today though you know
what I mean we know a lot of people that
are like that yeah but you know at the
time yeah at the time he was she stood
out yeah there was nobody like that and
honestly I still don't think there's
anybody like that I don't think there
ever will be ever again he was he was
breaking into a virgin territory so to
speak no I'm talking about also sounded
yeah yeah cuz no fourteen-year-old girl
there weren't many guys like that you
know back in those days that especially
at his age get younger guys emulating
him yeah he was already in his 40s so
back in the seventies he was doing cool
[ __ ]
well yeah although you know doc people
don't know this David Bowie faked it
until he made it really he wasn't famous
and test out you gotta do yeah he wasn't
really famous until I gave he just acted
famous yeah yeah when that list dance
album came out that's when he got famous
yeah I mean I had heard of him before
that obviously but he was like at home
like a number ground guy yeah he was
that was very alternative right yeah
back then that would be
yeah you listen to that like Iggy Pop in
the boat when that blitz dance album
came yeah that was a huge man it was
just all over MTV and I sort of got that
night driving five minutes yeah
let's dance over and over again and cat
people and I love David Bowie but I got
so [ __ ] sick of that video modern
love yeah the song and that's what
really made him the man that we remember
today
yeah that that album and that album was
a fantastic album Stevie Ray Vaughan did
guitar on that yeah man it was a good
album not my favorite of his obviously
but I actually think scary monsters was
my favorite his below is my fear low is
good too
yeah but he didn't have a bad album no I
don't I don't think I've ever heard
about glass spider was not a strong
album but even that had at least three
or four good songs yeah I remember that
being alright it's okay man
so as I said if you have not seen
labyrinth from 1986 its Muppets and
David Bowie yeah and all kind of like
sexual innuendos and the movie is
supremely drinkable I mean you know if
you you can sing a lot especially if you
kind of have nostalgia by the era and it
looks great on blu-ray it looks
fantastic on parallelled I've never seen
I didn't know the movie would look that
good until the other day you guys seen
on VHS yeah well and you can watch it
over and over because just like look at
all the [ __ ] puppets and [ __ ] in the
background man because there's all kind
of [ __ ] going on and the riddles I'm
happy I haven't I don't really
understand every riddle in it yeah I was
the one like about the worth the two
doors and one of them leads to certain
death yeah that's a pretty common riddle
though like I've seen different verse
and then the other one about who asking
who and who tells the truth and who lies
Jill don't really that's like I said
that's a pretty common like yeah I went
through that
the old days but yeah so that's why when
I saw that in the movie I was just kind
of like oh I don't think through that
cuz I doesn't like some other ones like
but there were other little riddles in
there I don't really remember him off
Hanna have to watch it again there was
some of them that I didn't quite get
yeah yeah and I was the I was gonna
reach out to Jared said that was kind of
slick that I didn't really quite get I
had to watch it again yeah cuz like I've
really only seen this movie like three
times I mean this is a really good like
I said it's you know Terry Jones from
Monty Python I mean I wrote the script
even though he said well like so much
other so many other people like did
versions of it that he doesn't really
feel like it's just exclusively his
anymore but it has a lot of his
trademark kind of you know wit in it
yeah I feel like that's it you know what
we should do I don't know why I just
thought of this but it's just thinking
it's thinking of Monty Python we should
do Time Bandits yeah I love that [ __ ]
movie I don't think I've seen it you
haven't seen it I've seen bits of it I
don't think I've seen the whole oh my
god David Warner is it we'll see it it's
[ __ ] great I want to revisit Brazil
too yeah yeah there's also a bunch of
other ones I want to revisit oh we have
so many movies yeah you guys and another
thing is I will vouch for the soundtrack
or I will vouch for the score on
labyrinth the music is [ __ ] awesome
oh yeah yeah really good cuz I think
Bowie did five songs cuz he wrote that
chilly down song you dude that the
fireese do even though he doesn't sing
it yeah but um not just the Bowie song
so everything everything on yeah there's
other four songs and then like that yeah
the rest of the score is also fantastic
yeah but yeah this way you could be kind
of drinking Kukulcan you're drinking you
know which this in case you guys don't
know me cool
the tequila drink I drink but you can
sit there and drink tequila and just
every every bit of that score it was
pulling me into the movie oh yeah that's
pulled into it and I've seen though it's
not serious it's fun it's a fun movie
yeah you know I was pulled into like I
said it's got serious messages yeah I
mean it's pretty fun like just the way
she goes through this I like to decipher
mythology and there's a lot of stuff in
there I need to see it again yeah they
used a lot of I mean
from like a lot of different sources you
know it definitely but yeah so like I
said if you haven't seen it you've got
little tween girls that haven't seen it
they probably wish it I mean you know
bonus package it's not the 80s anymore
but I don't know what tween girls are
into now I think the movies kind of in
its own time because it's a fairy tale
yeah it is kind of timeless in its own
way and I think it's one of the best if
not the best fantasy from that too
because I I love Legend I mean mostly
cuz it's him curry obviously being dark
legend was a pretty movie I didn't like
the movie that much I didn't like Tom
Cruise in it really I've only seen a
movie once and I thought he annoys me
generally I saw it in the movie theater
when it came out I think I did you know
high school friends and girls are with
us and I remember being blown away by
the visuals it is gorgeous sparkly but I
didn't like the movie yeah I thought it
was kind of happen and it was much too
lately but um I can see yeah I can see
what you're saying I mean it doesn't
have like a huge amount of story to it
it's just it's a very simple fairy tale
right from that same era you know what I
like better the Last Temptation of
Christ and that had David Bowie did yeah
Dafoe was in that too yeah and [ __ ] went
down between me and the girl and the
girl I was dating and and and Steve and
his girl you know it's thought about oh
so there was like an there was [ __ ]
going down yeah yeah had baggage yeah
you're having an orgy yeah that's weird
I mean Steve I didn't of the crime me
and my buddy Steve were friends to this
day we kind of he came over and visit us
about a year ago mm-hm
and we had our we had our Christ Union
moment where the Spirit of Christ
centered upon us and we became God men
like India you would have God man
kind of like a Jedi all right okay yeah
during that movie that's just very funny
to me that that would that that would be
something you guys have been watching
yeah yeah and I was dating Cheryl who
was his ex-girlfriend oh man yeah so it
was mid his old girl and his new
girlfriend let's watch ah and she knows
her role well she was a redhead and she
was just as endowed as you is a boob
girl that was the beginning of my
fixation with that's not a fixation it's
a healthy respect i yeah maybe yeah
people's why we don't know that but I
yeah naturally I read that I've been
dying to black for a long time just
because it's easier but although I was
thinking the other day that I might go
back because for a while if you've seen
like old pictures of me like from you
two or three years ago I had it like
bright bright red and uh I was thinking
maybe I should go back so it's a pain in
the ass like to maintain cuz it fades
really quick but I had a tire like every
week but uh I kind of miss it yeah I
might get back to that Janet we'll see
but yeah watch labyrinth yeah awesome
and seriously make a drinking game out
of it every time David Boies junk shows
up on screen take a shot you will die of
liver failure before the movie is a
weapon it is a well executed movie very
well handcrafted by masters it's a very
well-written movie on all levels in
terms of like musically yeah how the
story flows yeah and also like the that
mythological content of the move
everything yeah it's just a very good
movie of its type yeah very good and
like I said it's Muppets everybody loves
the [ __ ] mambas yeah if you don't love
the Muppets get out actually these
Muppets are proof this CG and all that
well yeah you know this movie could not
be done with CG and get that same it
just wouldn't it would not be right it
wouldn't be the same no it's just really
what oh yeah
so you know check it out and that will
do it for this movie retrospective and
like
we're not gonna do the little ending
thing anymore just go to our patreon you
guys know you do what you do help us out
on patreon send us some Teddy does it do
whatever you want yeah you got a deal
or the you know or the fudge that was
yes subscribe share like yeah that
actually helps yeah more than anything
you know just give us a little thumbs up
[ __ ] I'm sorry Sharon yeah you think you
know who you think would like it and
stuff like that so we will see you next
time